from his role as a part of this gang and
multiple back to the Future movies -
wicked cow in Titanic Billy Zane was
once a reliably dashing presence on
screen both big and small
he doesn't seem to pop up to provide his
quirky charm as much anymore however and
we wondered what he's been up to
recently Zane has apparently been in
over 20 different projects since 2014
and has an army of dedicated fans what's
it like knowing you've got an army of
Zane heads around the world they might I
mean because maniacs it's another day so
why aren't we actually seeing him here's
why you don't see Billy Zane much
anymore and how that could change he's
not a leading man Zane scored a series
of hits with supporting appearances and
projects like Titanic dead calls and
charm but on the handful of occasions in
which he was the lead actor in a
big-budget Hollywood movie he tended to
strike out shake for example the flashy
1996 superhero movie The Phantom
property from the 1930s might not be the
best things to adapt to the big screen
which we are reminded of again and again
with films like The Green Hornet and The
Lone Ranger and the shadow so it's
probably not really Zane's fault the
Phantom was intended to be the start of
a franchise but it made just 17 million
dollars at the box office that franchise
never materialized
and while the park got James Cameron's
attention it didn't land Zane a leading
role he can't escape Titanic any time
Zane makes the rounds to promote a new
project interviewers don't want to talk
about it all they want to discuss is
Titanic sure it was once the
highest-grossing movie of all time and
spent more than a dozen weeks at the
number one movie at the box office and
he of course played the villainous
controlling cow expertly but it's time
to move on people is it annoying that
people love the movie like they do I
hate it really no you know but it's the
gift that keeps giving is such a great
honor you've made it clear that he's
aware of how lucky he was to be in one
of the most popular movies of all time
and there is the overwhelming Titanic
phenomenon no ill will but it must be
tough to get out of the big boat shadow
his TV series are flops in the summer of
2016 Jane had one of his highest profile
gigs in years with the soap gilt in
which Jane played stand gut
a fashionable scheming defense lawyer
who has to navigate a foreign legal
system the series was cancelled after
one short season Jane even played an
important role in the Amazon original
series Mad Dogs as the quirky roguish
Milo apart most definitely in his
wheelhouse
even if spoiler alerts he dies in the
first episode nevertheless scarcely a
month after its debut Amazon announced
there would be no second season
barring any ghostly Billy Zane
appearances or flashbacks from ever
happening back in 2010 they even seemed
to have a promising role in ABC's legal
drama the deep end but that show was
killed prematurely also after just six
episodes Zane also had a recurring role
in the 2009 ABC sitcom Samantha Who
which was also put out of its misery
midway through his second season to put
it simply Zane's TV efforts have always
been doomed but it's not like he doesn't
have other projects going on they're
just a little less visible he makes his
own movies they might not always be in
front of the camera but he stays active
in moviemaking as a principal partner in
a production company and content
distributor called radioactive giant the
company's produced a handful of modest
movies including killing Winston Jones
and the acclaimed documentary searching
for Eddie running wolf and back in the
late 90s zayn produced and starred in a
labor of love called i woke up early the
day I died a silent film based on an
unproduced screenplay left behind by
famed bad movie maker Ed Wood he's busy
selling chicken nothing catches
fast-food customers attention quite like
a change in a change beloved mascot and
KFC has taken full advantage of this
over the last few years after decades of
existing mainly as a kindly kind of
greasy cartoon voiced by Randy Quaid a
real-life Colonel Sanders started
appearing in KSC's commercials again
start with a twist instead of an
anonymous actor playing the part
KFC began using well-known faces like
SNL vet norm MacDonald's and stand-up
comic Jim Gaffigan they joined the
Colonel Sanders lineup in early 2017
slathering himself in gold paint to help
roll out the restaurants line of Georgia
gold chicken I put gold on my legs my
thighs went
as KFC CMO Kevin Hoffman explained the
idea to hire Zane was directly inspired
by his past as a villainous rich dude
which is supposed to underscore the idea
that anyone can dig into a bag of
drive-through poultry if it's good
enough for Billy Zane it's good enough
for us
that's good chicken right it's not the
first time Thane has been in a food
commercial though cookie but it's
definitely the least embarrassing the
return of Billy Zane they may not be an
a-lister headlining giant movies anymore
but that's not his niche anyway he's
more of a character actor handsome
enough to play cads charismatic Goines
and engrossing weirdos that said he
still continues to work as often as you
like he's got multiple movies set for
release in the future including the
post-apocalyptic sci-fi movie blue world
order and the comedy the last party with
fellow 90 survivor Sharon Stone and Gina
Gershon in short veins got versatility
and it continues to keep in busy even if
we have to try a little harder to see
him in action do you say plus he's a
cool dude listen your friend Billy's
name is it cool dude thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to